welcome to elimination Creek Country
Club I believe you know your way around
- just give me a drink this up you are
very depressed
the club is nice I'm getting almost as
much rest as I did in the wild card game
yeah
now all the charities know I have three
times off season I won't break a
football can just wanna hey maybe I'm
sorry sir starters only at the club I'm
a lead I'll be one of Washington's five
starting quarterbacks next year not
again
never joke believe in yourself all right
well great season everyone see you next
year much love by the way man I'm
totally cool with outbursts so now on my
fourth OC has left I have to wonder am I
the problem cannonbaugh tough
elimination man that's okay this time
last year I was legally dead hello
putting it on oh no my power zone I'm
transforming back to Lucy's an egg so
the trick is did you have your family
yelled the owners today must be the
players on the playoff course across the
street why are you having fun this is a
game
hello you if you feeling dangerous
subscribe to this channel to watch more
episodes oh I'm so light for this haters
gonna hate